You as a leader,
right?
There's actually
millions
of people that follow you,
right,
that listened to you,
that respect what you say.
And they,
they truly follow your lead.
I mean,
clearly they follow your lead.
We saw this with,
uh,
with the,
the launch of,
or the release,
what's it called?
When a book comes out when my book comes out.
Yeah,
you'd kind of predicted everything that was going to happen to a tee of like
VIP.
When we talk about this book,
it's going to,
you can people go and buy it.
That's got it.
And so people clearly follow you and listen to what you say
as a leader.
And I don't know if you've perceived herself that way,
but you are a leader.
Two questions.
One,
where do you think he falls short and too
in more important,
where are you trying to lead people?
Yeah,
these are good.
Uh,
so I haven't thought of myself as a leader,
uh,
but
I think that two terms sometimes get used interchangeably and I view them as
very different.
So as a leader,
if I'm looking through that lens at myself,
I think I'm very good at
affecting national conversations and steering the attention of groups to one
thing for sustained periods of time.
I think I'm very good at that and helping people to prioritize.
If I were to view myself as a manager,
I think I have many deficiencies.
Uh,
and one of them would be,
and this has been a help and a hindrance,
as many things are,
uh,
inpatients,
I have extremely high standards and hold myself to just,
yeah,
a ridiculous degree of expectation for perfection,
which of course leads to a lot of the problems we've talked about earlier.
But on the flip side,
I get a lot done in part I think because of that is,
is a driver that can also damage relationships very quickly and it can,
in a management environment,
uh,
cause hurt feelings and people to not put forth their best because they feel
like they are being criticized and not lauded for their successes.
And in part that is because as an athlete,
I really,
and hope,
hopefully it doesn't sound weird or I don't really care if it sounds weird,
it actually in sports and in business,
my general feeling was,
and I remember mentor early on said something like this to me.
He said,
don't tell me about the good stuff.
The good stuff takes care of itself.
Just tell me about the bad stuff.
And that's been my personal policy for myself,
but that does not always translate well to team environments.
So that,
that I think is my,
my,
my homework that,
uh,
and,
and a deficit that I've been working hard to correct for the last few years is
getting better at managing people who do not necessarily conform to that mindset
at all times,
which I think can be,
uh,
a big problem when it's,
when it's out of control,
but that,
that would be the biggest deficit.
But if we're,
if we're defining leader as someone who can put forth a vision or an objective
or catalyze a movement and move attention and people in one direction,
I feel like I'm,
I'm quite good at,
at,
at mitigating the risk of that.
Uh,
because for instance,
people think that the haters,
this is a very popular word on the Internet and not all critics are haters of
course,
important to be able to take criticism and feedback,
but many people who were thrust into a position where they have the opportunity
to lead people virtually on a,
on the Internet,
which is a huge responsibility.
And I take it extremely seriously,
worry about,
say their detractors causing problems.
It's not the detractors in my experience.
They can do the most damage.
It's the die hard fans who get the message wrong,
who get the directive and misinterpreted that that is where you have to do
damage control and to think ahead.
So I think,
I think I'm quite good at that as far as where I'm leading people,
if I'm leading them anywhere.
Uh,
I,
I've always,
I shouldn't say always,
but for the last at least five years,
thought of my goal as creating a benevolent army of
super learners effectively who can teach intern 10 additional people each the
same skillset.
So to propagate a toolkit that enables people to be elite problem solvers
instead of accidental,
haphazard problem creators is,
has been my goal for at least the last five years.
Explicitly teaching people how to learn so they can teach people how to learn.
That's right.
And part of learning is problem solving.
So you buy by definition,
getting people who are good at dissecting problems,
testing assumptions.
That's where I'm leading people now.
That's,
that's solid.
I mean that's obviously a really positive thing.
I always talk about the fact that,
you know,
I want to help people learn how to learn.
I talk about that all the time and I've said that before on the podcast.
We will teach people how to,
not,
not what to think,
but how to think.
Obviously,
I'm not
the same scale that you are in terms of volume of masses of people,
but there's definitely some people out there that I think are following me in
some way.
And that might be a strong word,
but I always think of that what I'm trying to get people to do,
if you're following me,
I'm really trying to get you to follow yourself and lead yourself.
I don't,
you know,
lead yourself.
Okay.
You see it my path.
That's cool.
My Path was good.
I like my path now.
Forged your path,
you know,
figure out where you want to go,
how you're going to get,
how you're going to get stronger,
how are you going to get faster,
how you're going to get smarter,
how you're going to get,
how are you going to get better.
And I always think that those answers work best when they don't come from
somebody else,
but when they'd come from yourself.
Absolutely.
And I think also the teaching people
how to learn,
uh,
enabling
my audience to learn how to learn.
And when I say that I mean 1,000 times faster than would be expected in a lot of
domains.
That's only one leg of the stool.
So let's say there are three legs,
the other two would be teaching them to dissect and manage fear and then the
third leg would be teaching them to be emotionally aware and resilient in that I
think is covered largely by stoicism if you take it as a practice and not as
something to passively ingest.
Yeah.
And I just talked about stoicism on my last podcast because somebody hit me up
on Twitter and says,
do you practice stoicism?
And I was like,
no,
I just said no because I pretty terse on Twitter and,
and the guy kind of wrote back,
I don't want to say he was offended and I don't want to rehash the whole story
cause I just talked about in the last podcast.
But you know,
he said,
hey,
well you know what's wrong with stoicism?
And I never wrote back.
I'm like,
man,
there's nothing wrong with stoicism.
I,
I get it.
But for me to say that I practice it or even that I learned it from studying the
agents is not true.
I didn't go to Princeton.
I,
you know,
I didn't study when I was in high school.
I wasn't an over achiever.
I was an underachiever.
I was,
uh,
I was up troublemaker.
So I didn't learn anything about stoicism until much later in my life.
My roots aren't,
my beliefs aren't founded on what I read.
They're founded on what I lived.
And it's just,
it,
does it make sense?
Yeah.
When I look at it now and people have always asked me,
are you going to do Marcus Aurelius on them?
I'm going to do Marcus Aurelius on the podcast.
And really all I be saying is like,
look,
Mark Israelis said this thousands of years before I did awesome.
And,
but I would love this,
be all educated,
but I wasn't.
I was just,
I went down the path that I went down and experience the things that I
experienced in my life and I came to the same conclusions that these ancients
came to.
So it's an interesting dynamic.
No,
it is.
And I think it's worth noting also that if you find anyone who is consistently
good at operating at a high level in stressful environments,
the tools are the same.
Exactly.
I mean if you read one of my favorite books,
Musashi historical fiction,
fantastic book,
it's all the same shit.
You read that stoicism,
stoicism and Seneca was my real introduction but that didn't come into my life
until 2004 so it was after graduation.
For those of you that want me to do Musashi on this podcast,
I'm not going to do it.
Not going to do Musashi and I'll tell you why and if you've read it,
you know you can't.
You got to go through Musashi to get to the end,
got to go through the whole thing to get the head.
It is one of the best rewards in all of literature to get to the end and the
end.
This is a what's a,
how many pages is Musashi's 978 massive book and it's,
and you have to read the whole thing and it's all good.
But it all comes and it's literally,
I think in my copy because I always laugh about this,
it is two or three pages from the end of the whole book.
It's weird.
You get to the end of Musashi where you go,
damn,
that just happened on the pay office.
All the pay off is so good and the O and I'm not going to do it on here cause I
obviously I'd have to give away the pay off and so I'm not going to do that.
And you have to go and read Musashi.
It's,
it's awesome.
And the ending is just as good as it gets.
It's as good as it gets and it's historical fiction.
But that happened.
Oh that's documented.
Oh yeah.
And it doesn't get any better.
So read Musashi for yourself people.
Maybe I'll give a like a one year lead time and then I'll do it one year episode
in 100 maybe we'll do give people enough heads up,
episode 100 we'll go back and do massage if,
and I'll give you a spoiler alert at the beginning because massage is good when
you get to the end.
And Go.
Yeah,
that kind of like the Matrix.
What's that?
Is there like a spoiler at the end of the Matrix?
Oh,
does it end up thinking,
oh man,
I got to watch more movies.
Echo Charles movies.
Highly recommend babe involves a pig.
I think you'd like a junk,
didn't,
where do you do it?
Did you watch that a bunch of times they've got some saved story,
right?
Yeah,
I do,
so I,
I tend to,
when I write books,
so then I don't feel isolated.
I will generally I write late at night.
That's when I do my synthesis,
so I can do research and interviews and so on,
but I'll do my writing generally between 11:00 PM and 5:00 AM and so that I
don't feel like I'm sitting in a cave by myself.
I will generally listen to the same track or same album over and over again for
a given book.
That's how I focus and then I will have a movie playing mute in the background
so that I feel like there are other people in the room now.
At one point I was like,
all right,
I've seen the Bourne identity 5,000 times that I want to see it anymore.
I have seen,
because I was for the first book,
I've Seen Shaun of the dead,
which is a comedy 6,000 times.
I don't want to watch that anymore cause I'll just say,
I'll just watch it on repeat.
So I might watch a movie five times a night.
He'll go,
let's go to Amazon prime.
And I pull it up in the first movie that gets displayed as babe battled little
pig and farmer hogget and I put it on and I was like,
God,
this is hilarious.
This is all right.
Well I'll pick a real movie after this.
And I was like,
good God,
this is a fine film
and
the renegade duck.
Anyway.
Uh,
so yeah.
Yeah,
Babe.
I don't think you'd actually like,
I think you'd be disgusted with my recommendation,
but I don't watch enough.
I don't watch a lot of movies.
Um,
I think you'd like Narcos,
which is a miniseries.
Yeah,
I've heard of that.
That Pablo Escobar.
Right.
I think I've heard about that one.
I just then,
then you're,
then you're jumping into what,
like 30 hours of content that is only,
yeah,
you're looking at that 20 then you're in the vortex.
You know what?
I want to watch that like when I'm 78 I'll watch narcos.
Put that on my list.